IN, WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
TREATMENT, THINGS ARE A LITTLE
CREEPY OUT THERE ON THIS
HALLOWEEN NIGHT.
>> KEEP YOU'RE HOLY WATER CLOSE
THE CREEP STARTED THIS MORNING
WHEN THE LADIES OF THE VIEW
UNVEILED THEIR HALLOWEEN GETUPS
THEY WERE DRESSED AS TV HEROINES
, IS THE COSTUME TO PUSH
ABORTION RIGHTS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT YOU WOULD DO ON HALLOWEEN.
WITHIN THEY PARADED OUT CHILDRE
IN POLITICIZED COSTUMES WHAT DI
THEY CHOOSE TO CELEBRATE?
THIS.
CAN KEEP THE ON TRUMPS
MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE.
>> WHAT DID HE DO?
HE FLUSH THEM DOWN THE TOILET S
WE HAVE TRUMP AS A TOILET WITH
OUR FBI AGENTS.
>> AND THEN THEY WALKED THE POR
POOR CHILD OUT.
>> WITH A SLAP MARK ON HIS FACE.
LET THEM DRESS AS THINGS THEY'D
LIKE TO DRESS AS, NOT WITH THES
PARTISAN BOOMERS WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THEM AS.
>> RAYMAN, THE WHOLE THING IS
JUST HALLOWEEN HAS NOW BECOME
ITS OWN RELIGION.
EIGHT USED TO JUST BE A FUN
NIGHT AND NOW IT'S A NIGHT FOR
ADULTS TO DRESS UP THE KIDS OUR
KIND OF AN AFTERTHOUGHT BIRD
THIS IS ALL ABOUT THE ADULTS
FIRST.
>> I GUESS IT'S TO PROVE THAT
THEY CAN SKEW SCARE THE
DAYLIGHTS OUT OF AN AUDIENCE.
>> THIS THING LOOKS LIKE UP
BEFORE AND AFTER ADD.
WERE THEY TRYING TO SCARE HER T
DEATH?
AT FIRST I THOUGHT THIS WAS I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT SHE WAS DRESSE
AT, BUT WHAT DID SHE DO TO
DESERVE THIS?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN SHE STILL GET
DOWN.
>> I DON'T THINK I'VE SEEN HER
SINCE LIKE HOLLYWOOD SQUARES.
>> LOOK AT THAT.
THAT WAS SOMETHING ELSE.
>> BIDEN HAD IN THE SCARE LATE
LAST WEEK I UNDERSTAND AS WELL.
>> THANK GOODNESS, HIS VP
GUARDIAN WAS THERE TO KEEP HIM
FROM FALLING OFF THE STAGE.
♪
♪ TICKET THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO PUT A SHOCK BRACELET ON HIM
TO KEEP THEM IN THE STAGE AREA.
TALK ABOUT CREEPY WITH OBAMA AN
DOCTOR MIKE JILL HE WAS HOME
ALONE IN DELAWARE WHERE HE
AVERTED EARLIER WITH HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER I COULDN'T TELL I
IT WAS EARLY VOTING OR EARLY
GROPING.
BEWARE OF THE HAND.
WHICH I DO WANT?
>> THE SIDE.
IT IS JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
GIVEN THAT SPOOKY SCENE WE JUST
SUCK HIM AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TRICK-OR-TREATING TONIGHT WHEN
THE PRESIDENT ENCOUNTERED
CHILDREN, I THINK THEY PICKED
THE PERFECT SOUNDTRACK.
>> WHO NEEDS A MASK.
>> THEY WON'T LET HIM NEAR
VOTERS, BUT THEY WILL LET HIM
NEAR PEOPLE TOO YOUNG TO VOTE.
THIS IS TOO GOOD.
>> WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE HIM
PUTTING STICKERS ANYWHERE NEAR
THE AREA, THAT IS NOT NECESSARY.
MY GOODNESS.
TRULY SPOOKY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.